so the most common question i used to
get was
what about these millennials and i
did a thing i did a video and answered
that and that question went away which
is kind of good
the most common question that i get now
every single time the most common
question is
what if i believe in the infinite
mindset and senior leadership
is so finite minded how do i how do i
what do i do
um well if we adjust to an infinite
mindset we accept
that um a we can affect we can't change
people right
we can only change our own behavior we
can't force senior leadership to change
especially if we have no direct contact
with them but we can choose to become
the leaders we wish we had
right so the whole idea is say is to is
to work within the system you've got of
course
but to say okay we're going to build an
infinite minded team
and so amongst the people you work with
and it doesn't matter if you're in a
leadership position or not remember
leadership has nothing to do with rank
leadership is the responsibility to take
care of those around us so
you can take care of your boss too hey
boss you okay during this cobit how are
you
um um and start embracing those
uh those practices you know if the
organization doesn't have a good just
cause tell your team what your just
causes
and say why you love this job and how
this job is helping you advance your
just cause
start building trusting teams start
making the people you work with
feel like someone has their back that
someone cares about them as human beings
that you create a space where they can
be open and honest without judgment
uh um uh you
study your worthy rivals so that you can
be a better leader
but also ask the team what other teams
inside the company
are better than we are so that at
certain things so that we can become an
even better team
not because we want to beat them but
because we want to improve build that
sense
of constant improvement into the team um
be willing to change certain things
you know very often companies do things
because that's the way they've always
been done
but nobody's ever asked does it have to
be done this way and nobody ever asks
can i change it
and very often the answer is we don't
know why it's done this way and yes you
can change it
ask the questions i tell you one quick
funny story as a side about asking
questions
long ago when i had a job um i worked at
a large
ad agency and it was a fairly common
experience where
my boss would come into my office and
say the client wants this by wednesday
get it done i'd be like it's impossible
to get this done by wednesday
and he would say i don't know what to
tell you you have to get the client
wants it by wednesday
so one day i called the client
and i said hey i got this thing that you
asked for when do you need it by
because they said you have to have it by
wednesday and they went no i can have it
by friday or monday that's totally fine
it's because somebody said when do you
want it they said wednesday and
we went okay and then it became the
point is ask a question
sometimes we have more flexibility and
more freedom than we think we do
and then what ends up happening is you
build this wonderful high-performing
team
if you have an open-minded group of
leaders even if they're finite-minded
they're going to look at what you're
doing in your high-performing team with
higher loyalty better relationships and
they're going to say
what are you guys doing down there and
they may want to learn from you
if they're completely just you know in
their own world and short-term
metric-driven
they'll just leave you alone because
you're high-performing
and eventually some of the people will
leave that group and go join other teams
they'll either move on or get promoted
out
and they'll bring everything they've
learned and they'll take it to those
teams and they'll build
high performing infinite minded teams
and eventually the tail wags the dog
unfortunately we don't know how long it
takes depends on the organization
depends on the culture depends on the
people
but the tail can wag the dog i saw it
happen with a hundred thousand person
organization
and it took two years which i think is
unbelievably quickly
and it was completely without senior
leadership's help we saw the whole
organization
pivot just because the people started to
embrace new ideas